voilà bon bonjour à tous et à toutes
effectivement pour allumer des
étincelles un peu révolutionnaire pour
amener des changements je vous propose
deux question de temps et une boussole
et donc les deux questions on vous les a
présentés déjà mais je voulais répète
la première et qui
excusez moi qui est digne d'être citoyen
et la deuxième c'est les plus pauvres
sont ils des citoyens comme les autres
voilà donc les questions que j'aimerais
vous soumettre à la réflexion et au
débat est en fait à la veille des
élections quand on pense citoyenneté on
pense surtout
aux élections mais c'est dans un esprit
beaucoup plus large que je vais me
situer et les deux tendons jésus vous
parler c'est le temps de la révolution
française et le temps notre temps
donc vous allez voir pourquoi je je je
commence oui et puis j'ai oublié de vous
parler de la boussole la boussole est
bien en fait c'est un horizon de sens
que sont les droits de l'homme
donc la révolution française est un
moment important parce que c'est un
moment où deux sujets soumis au roi
ont pas on devient citoyen avec son mot
à dire pour participer au destin du pays
alors qu'est ce qui se passe c'est bien
l'assemblée constituante avant de
rédiger une constitution pour la france
est de régler les rapports entre les
gouvernants et les gouvernés
établi rédige une déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen après un mois
de débats non sans mal mais qui aboutit
à un ses oeuvres et l'article plus
premier dit les hommes naissent et
demeurent libres et égaux en droits et
l'article 6
les la loi est
la loi est l'expression de la volonté
générale tous les citoyens ont le droit
de concourir personnellement ou par
leurs représentants à sa formation
et pourtant la constitution de 1791
entérine un régime censitaire avec des
citoyens dits actifs
ceux qui peuvent payer des impôts qui
sont considérés comme dignes d'être
citoyens actifs et des citoyens dits
passifs les autres c'est-à-dire les
pauvres
et est en fait c'est considéré comme une
violation des droits de l'homme la plus
manifeste par des gens entre autres
comme robespierre et du coup il va ya
voir ça va devenir l'enjeu d'un des
enjeux pas loin d'être le seul de la
révolution puisque deux ans après la
constitution de 1793
aboli ces distinctions entre les
citoyens et la d'ici deux ans après à
nouveau la liste inclut la distinction
est rétablie dans la constitution de
1795 et puis il faudra attendre jusqu'en
1875 pour les hommes et 1945 pour le
droit des femmes
alors être citoyenne qu'est ce que ça
veut dire mais c'est intéressant de se
replonger dans l'époque de la révolution
parce qu'à cette époque là c'était bien
au delà du droit de vote les les
citoyens se rassembler dans dans leur
dans les villages ou dans dans le coup
dans les communes et par quartier par
exemple à paris c'est d'abord les
districts plus les sections et là il
échangeait à la fois sur le point de vue
local sur la police justice ou ou même
la propreté des rues ou encore le
secours aux pauvres par exemple pour
leur donner du travail et on pourrait
dire et puis aussi au niveau national il
j'ai il disait des représentants et même
discuter des lois et pouvait apporter
des propositions
et en fait on pourrait dire une
démocratie participative en quelque
sorte mais en fait pas du tout puisque
les plus pauvres ne peuvent y participer
donc c'est pas une démocratie
or l'un des programmes protagonistes de
la révolution qui s'appelle louis pierre
dufour ni dont j'ai suivi les traces
dans ma thèse
explique lui pourquoi au contraire
c'est injuste et indigne et au contraire
les plus pauvres doivent rentrer dans le
processus aucune loi juste ne peut vous
arracher le droit d'être citoyen
c'est-à-dire le droit de de s'exprimer
de s'assembler d'échangés de réclamer de
délibéré de s'instruire réciproquement
de se couvrir mutuellement et ses
assemblées devait être local devait
peut-être établir cette fraternité entre
les différentes classes sont ses mots à
lui être des écoles où se formeront les
hommes dignes d'administrer la commune
et de représenter la nation
alors quelles sont les raisons invoquées
pour exclure les moins fortunés ou celle
de dufourny qui est très explicite on va
en contraste pour les inclure alors pour
les exclure on sait des raisons sont
très liés au regard porté par rapport au
travail et la société scindée en deux
entre les gens de bras qui travaillent
de leurs mains et les autres qui pensent
et décident
et ils sont considérés par des gens
comme say yeah sein des grandes
législateur de leurs émissions comme des
machines de travail c'est dire les
termes employés pour justifier la
distinction entre actifs et passifs
n'ayant lieu leur humanité d'être
pensants et paradoxalement ils sont
accusés d'être des fauteurs de trouble
de vouloir changer les tas de choses
l'état des choses existant parce qu'il
n'ya de ressources pour eux que dans une
alternative de révolution dit boissy
d'anglas ce rapporteur du comité de
constitution en 1795 donc sondé rendre
gars qui enferme dans la fatalité de
leur état considéré comme dans l'ordre
des choses qu'on ne peut changer
du fournissait que les pauvres sont des
êtres pleins de besoin vous voulez des
travaux pénibles qui usent leur santé
comme dit seyes mais il ajoute que ces
travaux
sont insuffisants pour que leur salaire
est insuffisant les travaux sont pas
toujours sont pas toujours assurée
il sait leur différence instructions de
mode de vie de disponibilité leur
dépendance mais pour lui ce sont pas des
raisons de les exclure au contraire il
révèle la nécessité de leur accorder les
droits prioritairement parce qu'ils sont
sont eux qui ont des besoins les plus
pressants et qui souffrent le plus
il veut montrer que ceux qui payent des
impôts les propriétaires ne sont pas
forcément les meilleurs citoyens ou les
plus aptes à gouverner comme le dit c
est ce parce qu'ils sont les plus
instruits du cs mais pour du fournissent
il leur manque la connaissance de ce que
vivent et pensent les infortunés
sont pas forcément les meilleurs
citoyens et ils en mesurent les
conséquences le risque de loi trop dur
pour les pauvres
voilà donc pour cette approche
historique le deuxième temps donc notre
temps
aujourd'hui la démocratie paraît assurée
et triompher mais en ce moment on n'y
croit plus que jamais d'ailleurs parce
qu'elle est des deux de fortes tensions
la menace et
on a plus que jamais envie de la
défendre et le désastre de la seconde
guerre mondiale avait provoqué la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme de 1948 pour que jamais plus ça
ne recommence et nous guider vers un
projet de société plus en harmonie avec
notre nature humaine
est ce intéressant aussi de relier le
pré le priant de se redire le préambule
de cette déclaration il engage tous les
peuples et toutes les nations à rendre
effectif le droit pour tous en vue de
cet idéal commun à atteindre
l'avènement d'un monde où les êtres
humains seront libres de parler de
croire libéré de la terreur et de la
misère crocs proclamé comme la plus
haute aspiration de l'homme
or quelle est la réalité aujourd'hui
elle est implacable il ya une frange
importante de la population française
qui vit encore dans la pauvreté la
grande pauvreté ou la misère une autre
crainte de tomber et à l'échelle du
monde plus de 2 milliards d'hommes
femmes et enfants
alors que faire
refuser le scandale de la misère faire
avec les personnes et non pour elle
s'unir pour les respecter dans leurs
droits fondamentaux ou non de les gagner
d'illégal dignité de tous les êtres
humains c'est un chemin positif que j'ai
eu la chance de voir émerger c'est le
privilège de l'âge
je vais vrai inscrit le fondateur d'atd
quart monde après plus de dix années
où il a vécu au bidonville de noisy le
grand et avec les premières premiers
volontaires qui lui rejoignait et dans
d'autres bidonvilles et cités de france
faisait le même constat que dit dufourny
tous ces personnes sont abandonnés qui
vivent dans des conditions intolérables
sont abandonnés par la société alors
qu'au contraire ils en auraient besoin
d'elle et la participation serait
indispensable et prioritaire pour bâtir
avec eux une société plus juste et plus
humaine libérer du fléau de la misère et
donc c'est comme ça qu'en 1968 69 il
forge le nom de quart monde par analogie
au terme de tiers-monde et ceux qui
venaient d'être
changé aussi et celui de quatrième ordre
terme utilisé par dufourny pour nommer
ceux qui avaient été exclus des
assemblées du tiers état ce nom de quart
monde signifie que les plus pauvres du
monde entier aspire à être reconnus
comme des citoyens à part entière et à
ce que leur cause vouloir sortir de la
misère soit entendu
il s'agit d'un acteur collectif d'une
transformation qui implique une démarche
un mouvement vers les plus pauvres
alors comment l'opinion publique et les
élus pour étiez pourront-ils se
représenter pour présenter les pauvres
et les plus pauvres s'ils ne le
connaissent pas ce qu'ils vivent et
pensent 1 verte est du fourni c'est pour
cette raison qu'il est important de
donner aux personnes dans cette
situation les moyens de s'exprimer et de
se former personnellement et
collectivement
comme par exemple dans les universités
populaires quart monde j'étais
d'ailleurs ce matin
ces espaces citoyens leur permettent de
voir qu'ils ou elles n'ont pas ne sont
pas tout seuls dans cette situation ce
qui leur donne une sacrée force et de
sortir de la honte ou de l'agressivité
et de devenir eux mêmes acteurs dans
leur quartier de représenter leur milieu
dans les instances démocratiques ya suel
réécoute de les connaître pour agir
ou encore les programmes de recherche
action formation pour le par le
creusement des savoirs entre les savoirs
de vie des personnes en grande pauvreté
les savoirs d'universitaires les savoirs
d'action des professionnels qui leur
permettent de construire une pensée
commune et ce même modèle aussi se
développe dans d'autres pays
là il ya eu un moment important dans
cette histoire c'est le rapport grande
pauvreté et précarité économique et
social
de 1987 travailler au conseil économique
et social
aujourd'hui le ceser conseil économique
social et environnemental
dont joseph wrésinski été le rapporteur
c'était un tournant important au niveau
de la connaissance des situations de
pauvreté en france que les collègues
sociologue reconnaissent aujourd'hui et
il a initié une nouvelle manière de
considérer les plus pauvres et la lutte
contre la pauvreté en termes de droits
de l'homme est en fait cela aussi
inspirer un rapport des nations unies
donc pour la l'échelle du monde et
les rapports qui a abouti
il ya eu un expert suite hassan experts
qu'il ya toujours depuis un expert
droits de l'homme et l'extrême pauvreté
et ça aboutit en dise 2012 a dès
l'adoption de principes directeurs
et dans tout ce chemin ces rapports ont
affirmé éprouver la nécessité de tenir
compte de l'avis et de l'expérience et
plus pauvres pour définir les politiques
et si je reviens l'avis du conseil
économique et social il a été à
l'origine du revenu minimum d'insertion
rmi qui est devenu rsa revenu de
solidarité active et de ses déclinaisons
dans les domaines de la santé et du
logement la cmu couverture maladie
universelle le dalo droit au logement
opposable
et plus et ensuite
dit la loi
d'expérimentation de dix territoires
0 chômeurs de longue durée qui par sa
réussite a été étendu à la loi de 2020 à
d'autres territoires
donc toutes ces lois ont été issus de la
prise en compte de la vie et
l'expérience des plus beaux même s'ils
sont toujours à remanier
il est le rapport préconisait une
politique globale contre la pauvreté il
suffirait pour cela une politique
d'envergure ce qui a abouti en
1998 est la loi d'orientation relative à
la lutte contre les exclusions qui a été
présenté à l'assemblée nationale par
geneviève de gaulle
et
et voilà c'est une loi provoque
prospective globale et parce qu'elle
considère l'ensemble des domaines de vie
qui correspondent à des droits et comme
le soulignait joseph réinscrit dans sa
contribution à la commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme
préparatoire à une réflexion pour le
bicentenaire des droits de l'homme année
de la chute du maire de belles rhin de
berlin les plus pauvres sont révélateurs
de l'invisibilité l'indivisibilité des
droits de l'homme
comment trouver un travail sans logement
vivre une vie chami descente
préserver sa santé s'instruire et vice
versa pour m'en trouver un logement
décent sans travail etc mais aussi sans
les droits civils et politiques
ce qu'on pourrait appeler le la même
pente que
cette notion qui était né aux états unis
où les capabilities de seine
est alors pour pour que ces droits
soient effectifs il fait aussi des
réseaux pour
pour des pour portissol s'assurer qu'il
soit effectif et les faire évoluer et
donc c'est des réseaux qui se sont pas
développés avec la volonté de suivre
chaque domaine avec des professionnels
des acteurs sociaux et institutionnels
des personnes en situation de précarité
grande pauvreté par exemple sur l'école
avec des avec des parents d'élèves de
deux
des parents en situation pauvreté et des
enseignants et des universitaires des
acteurs de dans l'école des politiques
etc
donc c'est on pourrait dire tout ce sont
des artisans de démocratie qui agissent
dans leur quartier leur métier partagent
les bonnes pratiques comme le réseau
culture le réseau logement le réseau
emploi le zoo écoles dont je parlais le
réseau santé le réseau enfance et
famille le réseau jeunesse est aussi oui
le réseau écologie et grande pauvreté
son laboratoire d'idées pour que les
personnes les plus défavorisées ne
soient pas des victimes collatérales
de
voilà de la bim
voilà du manque d'écologie mais au
contraire soit une source de proposition
et d'inspiration pour que la transition
écologique améliore les conditions
d'existence de tous parce qu'il n'ya pas
de transition écologique sans justice
sociale
là où des hommes sont condamnés à vivre
dans la misère les droits de l'homme
sont violés s'unir pour les faire
respecter est un devoir sacré ce sont
ces mots qui ont été gravées sur le
parvis des droits de l'homme et des
libertés ou trocadéro là où fut signée
la déclaration des droits de l'homme de
1948 et d'autres dalles portant ces
mêmes mots ont été reproduites dans de
nombreux lieux significatifs dans le
monde aux états unis voudraient l onu
au pied du mur de berlin
conseil de l'europe au burkina faso en
haïti à mexico ça m'agace car reims
reims à la cathédrale voilà est en fait
y en a plus de 50 jours
et elles sont l'occasion chaque 17
octobre qui est la journée des raids des
nations unies pour l'éradication de la
pauvreté des rassemblements sur les
quatre continents donne la parole aux
plus pauvres et à ceux à leurs côtés
et un rapport des nations unies de kofi
annan en 2006 sur l'impact de cette
journée se félicitait de
justement du rayonnement de la
mobilisation qu'elle avait créée dans le
monde il cette année ce sera le 30e
anniversaire de cette journée et il le
sait et ce justement débattra sur ce
thème
trente années de combat 30 défis
d'avenir pour vaincre analysé
alors pour conclure ben oui nous avons
de quoi nous inquiéter pour l'avenir des
années de la planète mais oui un monde
sans misère est possible si nous le
voulons
pour le bien de tous et tout comme le
montrent les exemples de ce schéma tracé
avec au bout comme boussole le droit
d'être un homme le droit d'être un
citoyen à part entière je vous remercie